um this is regarding the Forgiveness of
sins now I've heard Christians say that
let's say someone is Born Again commits
their life to Jesus that in that moment
their previous sins are forgiven now yes
they they describe this as a
instantaneous thing well in my head I
think of it almost as a covenantal thing
that if they do not either or brother
it's both you're right because the
moment you are converted all that sins
up to that point have been wiped out
but that doesn't address the sins you
commit
afterwards yeah so what happens when I
am a convert from Islam I get baptized
all those sins are washed away but from
that moment on does that mean I won't
sin of course I'll sin does that mean I
don't need to ask for forgiveness of
course I do that's why the church has
confession repentance restor
because Jesus himself taught Believers
the following watch here look what he
taught this is Jesus so Jesus saying
even as Believers born of the spirit
you're going to be constantly seeking
forgiveness and asking for forgiveness
so God can forgive you but there's a
condition if you expect God to forgive
you for all your post-baptismal sins
then God expects you to forgive those
who offend you when they ask
here you got you guys see how it works
so it's not either or it's both and my
patron saint is St Jerome someone told
me that St Jerome was an angry person
like me he was a brilliant man not that
I'm brilliant and he was holy and I'm
not I pray I become holy but he was an
angry person like me so I said hey what
better Saint than have an angry Saint to
sympathize with me anyway here it is
Matthew 6 vers
8-15 do do not be like them for your
father knows what you need before you
ask him pray then like this Our Father
who art in heaven Hallowed be thy name
thy kingdom come thy will be done on
Earth as it is in heaven give us this
day our daily bread and forgive us our
debts so the Lord is telling you the
model prayer you should be constantly
seeking forgiveness from your heart
because you're not going to be sinless
ain't happening but that doesn't mean
you excuse it as we also forgive in our
debtors condition
why is God going to forgive your
post-baptismal sin folks are you
listening please
listen why will God forgive your post
baptismal sins because you forgive those
who sin against you because
notice and forgive us our debts as we
also have forgiven our debtors lead us
not in temptation but live Us from Evil
for if you forgive men their trespasses
your heavenly father will also forgive
you but if you do not forgive men their
trespasses neither will your father
forgive your trespasses so much for once
saved always
saved yeah yeah I see that so it's not
either or Albert it is a covenantal
relationship but what it's saying is how
do you enter the Covenant by your
baptism when you're baptized all your
sins are wiped away you have a clean
State you start as a babe the Bible says
you become a spiritual baby and the more
you drink the milk of the word then you
mature then you start feasting on the
meat of the word you go from milk to
meat and you go from a babe to becoming
fully mature in Christ and through that
process you will sin and what the Lord
says confession repentance restoration
but if you don't forgive you won't be
forgiven everyone with me there you got
it yeah it's both and yeah so and let me
show you that you start as a babe you
ready first
Peter uh let me show you here
verse 1
21-25 212 okay watch here you guys I
hope you're
learning I even had to cut out an event
I was supposed to do something for this
session so I hope you appreciate it by
the grace of God here though through him
through Jesus because of Jesus my trust
in Jesus I have confidence in God why
because Christ has been raised Immortal
and therefore I have the Assurance God
will raise me because God raised him
from that gave him glory so that your
Faith and Hope are in God if this God is
that powerful to raise Jesus Immortal
then he has the power to sustain me and
glorify me now watch having purified
your souls by
obedience by your obedience to the truth
it's not just SOL as Martin Luther
defined it for sincere love of the
Brethren notice you obey the truth and
you must sincerely love your brothers
because that's what Jesus said by this
they shall know you're my disciples
you're love for one another all right
love one another earnestly from the
heart you have been born a new there it
is you've been born again not of
perishable seed but of imperishable the
seed that cannot corrupt the seed of
God's word through the living and
abiding word of God so you notice God's
word is liken to seed and if you see
what the word for seed is guys you want
to be shocked Albert you know what the
word for seed is no I don't know what is
it Sperma
speros uh I see so like a babe makes
sense Sperma sperm let me prove it to
you you have been born a new not a
perishable but of perishable through the
living and abiding word of God so notice
your spiritual birth is being likened to
natural birth a seed is planted you're
conceived you're born let me prove it to
you let me finish this for All Flesh is
like grass and all its Glory like the
flower of grass the grass withers and
the flower Falls but the word of the
Lord abides forever so what's the word
of God the word of God that you heard
preached you see that Albert the word of
God is the preaching that's oral and
written right yes okay when you then
hear that word and accept it that's
God's spiritual seed being planted in
you to become a child of God so here let
me show you the word what is the word
seed so you guys don't think Sam you're
tripping man you're on drugs Sam you're
pervert Sam all it's about sh and you
know okay now watch here what's the word
for Sperma
people okay having been born of at spas
perishable okay now let me go
here Spas let's see here I'm gonna give
it to you one second brother spora a
sewing okay right here all right I'm G
to find it to you believe me there is
the word speros don't think I was just
lying man SPO don't say Sam you're lying
man no I'm not I so spread scatter I'll
get it for you just give me a second can
you take it easy all right no rush let
me give you the first Peter now here
it's Spas but it is synonymous with
Sperma speros I'll get it just one
second guys all right let me finish this
and I'll give it to you ready because I
want you to show you so you're born of
the seed of God so put away all malice
and all guile and insincerity and envy
and all slander like newborn
babes long for the pure spiritual Mar so
when you're born at the seed of God you
become what a b
baby and as a baby you can only handle
spiritual
milk then you grow that by it you may
grow up salvation then you handle the
meat of scripture and feast on the meat
of scripture so now let me do this if
you have another question let me get you
the word where the word for seed is
spermato so you don't think I'm like Sam
I don't see Jesus in Sam you have
another question as I find this for
because I don't want you to go until I
find it for you hold on wait or you
can't wait no I'm here I'm wait okay
first John 39 We
Ready first John 3:9 We Ready Mister yes
I'm ready you guys don't think Sam
you're tripping it says sport it doesn't
say Sperma yeah that's a synonym
just answer he's asking excellent
questions Albert I rejoice in the day
when you're gonna get baptized and
surrender Jesus because you're on the
way you ask beautiful questions I was
baptized as a as a child oh okay well
then you don't need to just come back to
being restored okay here you go on the
screen anyone having been born of God
right sin not practiced because seed of
him sper in him the Sperma of God is in
you Sperma first John 3:9 you guys
thought I was lying didn't
you yeah the phrase a man doesn't
shouldn't spill his seed it's a it's a
common kind of euphemism for it did
everyone got it